would invite jean-luc de marchi
director-general 4dg trade to come up to
open today's proceedings thank you Peter
Commissioner Minister chairman longer
deputy director-general of the ritual
Carl Bruner ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure to be here today to opens
European Commission's force European
trade policy day today will reflect on
where trade policy is heading and on
what it has delivered but will do this
against a difficult backdrop the paradox
today is that trade has never played a
more important role in delivering jobs
and growth
EU business has never been more
successful in global markets but the
same time trade policy has never been
under more scrutiny questions are being
asked about globalization about the
value of the multilateral rules-based
trading system and the capacity to of
try to contribute to a broader set of
policy or policy challenges has the
heart of sustainable development and the
universal values that underpin the
European Union today's program is
designed to answer many of these
questions there will be a mixture of
plenary discussion this morning and the
parallel sessions this afternoon first
on the military general trading system
secondly on the impact of technology and
sodium and the wider debate around trade
and globalization but we also leave
plenty of space to hear your views and
your voice
over my eight years as director of trade
a lot has changed not least the terms of
the debate around trade this will
certainly be a central theme for today
under the guidance of our Commissioner
we have delivered an impressive set of
modern trade agreements we have defined
a new trade for our agenda we have
delivered important legislative reform
ranging from an updating of our trade
defense tools to the recent political
agreement between Parliament that
Council on a framework for screening
foreign direct investment and we have
done all these more openly and more
transparently than ever before
transparency is important for two
reasons first it underpins political
accountability second it shows people
the results that you trade policies
achieving and we have more and more
positive practical examples of those
yesterday we launched the trade and job
report it shows that 36 million jobs in
the EU are linked to international trade
and that this figure is up from thirty
two point five millions which we found
in similar analysis in 2014 moreover
jobs supported by EU exports are better
paid than average the export related
wage premium amounts to twelve percent
in average more examples of the success
of the trade policy can be found in the
second annual FGA implementation report
which was adopted just three weeks ago
it should be a key tool for you in
uncaging in the debate around trade and
making people aware of the opportunities
of the you network of trade agreements
can offer it covers certifier agreements
with 62 partners it has a positive story
in many cases while also allowing us to
focus on issues that still need
to be addressed it shows that our
agreements have also delivered
significant boost for many different
sectors which are sometimes
paradoxically among the most sensitive
our negotiations such agri-food sector
the report also recalls progress in
implementing the new approach to trade
insatiable development found in all our
latest agreements at the same time the
report highlights our trade agreements
untapped potential for example in 2017
if you trade agreements were fully used
it means that if all the preferential
Duty were all used European companies
could have saved an additional 3.5
billion euros in duties on exports on
the top of already more than 8 billion
saved so a lot of work is still in front
of us so Commission together with the
member states and stakeholders is
looking at ways to improve information
and about our agreements so more
companies in particles smaller ones know
how to benefit so ladies and gentlemen
it's now time for our work to begin I
look forward to seeing what the moves
but I'm confident that today will be
rich
lively creative and stimulating so thank
you very much for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed jean-luc I'd
now like to invite the Commissioner and
Alan Beattie to come up and join us on
stage it's meant to be a fireside chat
but of course with Health and Safety
inside the Commission if I is not
possible but nevertheless please come up
take your microphone and the floor is
yours
well thank you very much um let me start
with you with a really easy question
good morning four years ago possibly the
worst thing you had to deal with was
100,000 protesters against TTIP on the
streets of Berlin and now you have
Donald Trump already lessons in dealing
with one in the other Wow an easy
question no I think the challenges are
quite different the protesters in Berlin
and by the way just outside here as well
regularly was of course a challenge but
but it was also something that allowed
us to change the the way we do trade and
to engage in a different way open up
more transparency more inclusiveness
jean-luc de Mathieu made reference to
this how we have formed the new trade
policy to try to regain some of the
Trust's that was not in there was a lot
of other feelings in those protests but
there was also a lack of trust towards
the way we do true we do trade and there
was a lot of anti-americanism so that's
and that was before Donald Trump came
came into office dealing with the
American administration is of course a
challenge for the whole world because it
is slightly unpredictable and it's
governed by by tweets but it's something
we have to do this is the the elected
representative of the American people
and everybody needs to have relations
with the US we have traditionally very
strong allies and friends across the
transept the the Atlantic and we need to
find ways where we can cooperate I think
those feelings are still very very
strong in the European Union and in the
US and we need to find ways to cooperate
the u.s. is so much more than than
president Trump so you mentioned the
internal debate within the EU has
changed partly because of trade for and
the engagements and so on what what
actual impact has Trump himself had on
the internal debate in the EU
I mean his trade seen differently
is the you know is it now part of a
different context to a different
narrative than what it was before his
election well I think we started to
change the narrative before by doing
this and working with Member States
working with Parliament's working with
the civil society opening up engaging in
in transparency and inclusiveness and
saying that that we should do trade
differently we are listening to the
concerns we are involving citizens we
are taking their advice we are now the
most transparent trade negotiator in the
world we have embedded our values in our
trade agreements we've made sure that we
are not lowering our standards and so on
and that started to change I'm not
saying that everything is fine but it
still but it started to change and then
I think with President Trump making
likely that he saw trade as something
that only they can only be one winner
and one loser and that trade wars are
good there is it win and that basically
trade is about tariffs and that created
a counter movement around the world I
would say I think the the countries of
the TPP that
the trans-pacific partnership is now
called see another in comprehensible
acronym anyway
they they decided that they wanted to
move on to show that this is a good
agreement if the u.s. is not in well too
bad we will continue and we had the
feeling also with trade agreements that
we've been negotiated with US and Japan
that okay let's hurry up to finish
because we can show that you can do good
trade agreements well you win where I
win they are sustainable they good trade
that good for our companies they're good
for our citizens we concluded with other
countries as well and we have speeded up
negotiations with with many so I think
that created a a reaction that we
believe that trade is a good thing and
that is why also we are working with all
these countries and we'll come back to
that later today how to strengthen and
modernize WTO because the multilateral
system needs to be the core of this how
you do trade well just take a specific
example the Japan FTA it was remarkable
how little objection there was within
two EU you know there it's a very good
agreement
do you think that how much that seemed a
bit late how much do you think it is the
nature of the agreement how much do you
think it is what you've just talked
about about the nature of trade changing
and how much is it possibly that's the
kind of people who are protesting about
trade have actually gone on to protest
about something else but you mean I
think one of the things I noticed at the
time as a veteran of the you know the
anti-globalization prototype I which I
mean I was covering not participating in
of the late 1990s and so forth is how
suddenly these demonstrations come out
of nowhere I think it's true to say that
the you know the Commission was totally
taken by surprise so is it possible that
that kind of thing won't come again that
a new Japan and another Japan deal
will suddenly see an upsurge in protests
again or have we seen that go for good
now well there are certainly people who
criticize elements of the the agreement
with with Japan and there are probably
people who think we shouldn't have that
trade agreement at all but I haven't
seen any
you know demonstrations or big crowds
against Japan anywhere in Europe neither
in India pan and I think there are many
things it's difficult to know which came
came first first of all this is an
agreement that is very far-reaching it's
opening up a lot of possibilities for
European agricultural industry for our
car industry for our wood industry etc
etc it goes very far in eliminating
tariffs and opening up market that has
been traditionally quite closed and
protected as as you know even if we've
been trading with Japan for a long time
and and it includes all these modern
aspects of a trade agreement it has
reference to the Paris climate agreement
it has an ambitious sustainable
development chapter we are agreeing on
many things where we want to cooperate
beyond you know the traditional trade
elements so that I think is an
opportunity that many countries and see
that we we can take take benefits of
that and also work I mean the moment
that TTIP was in the freezer the the
demonstration stopped more or less it
doesn't mean that all the the the misc
tenth and all they're the the questions
have totally disappeared but the moment
we took teacher away and we did the
demonstrations stopped and then at the
same time there was also a lot of
protest against the Canadian agreement
SATA which I think was considered as the
little evil sister of TTIP and as it
came at the same time it was so seen at
the same context had we had only Canada
agreement I think they wouldn't have
been so many many protests but now
Canada has entered into force since a
year ago heaven has not fallen upon us
democracy still in the European Union
and when there is a problem it's not
because of Canada so I think that has
calmed down as well and we listened to
the concerns there was also a lot of
concerns related to this famous acronym
is yes we listened to that we have
reformed it we have a new system now in
the Canadian and other agreements and we
are working very closely with other
countries to see if we can set up some
sort of multilateral investment court on
this so we have taken the the worries
inside the the policies of the
Commission maybe that has calmed Samsung
and and the but the only thing I can
notice that there are no more
demonstrations but they can come
tomorrow probably but maybe not on Japan
you mentioned how Trump had changed the
debate within the world and perhaps made
people click together a bit more it's
always been said the u.s. is has been
the anchor of the world trading system
you know going right back to the
beginning of the gap is the EU in a
position to take over that role can the
EU be a new anchor well the global world
trading system and many of the
international institutions that we have
after the second world war were created
by the US and many of them by the US and
Europe that was a new liberal world
order so we definitely need the u.s.
there and when the u.s. is there we can
do fantastic things together in the WTO
and in the trading system we have seen
that many many countries now are worried
about
unilateral action about countries acting
outside the the WTO and that's why we
are trying to come together to see can
we strengthen the WTO can we reform it
can we consolidate it and we are many
but of course it's difficult to do that
totally without the u.s. so we hope that
that they eventually win a cage and they
are I mean despite the different
difficulties we have and some of the
differences we are engaging with the US
on reforming the WTO that's actually
quite constructive discussions that we
have with the USTR together with the
Japanese as well okay ask about W reform
specifically in a bit but just to press
that you know one of the initiatives
that's come out to try and get the u.s.
back into the fold as it were is a
trilateral initiative between the EU the
US and Japan I think it is fair to say
that that was largely a Japanese
initiative or the Japanese provided the
momentum from the beginning and the EU
was possibly a bit reluctant to begin
with do you think first start do you
think that's true and second do you
think something like that is going to
off of the u.s. enough that they don't
turn away from multilateralism and back
towards a plurilateral a multilateral
system well that's hard to say it is
true that it was a Japanese idea and
they gathered us in in Buenos Aires when
there was the ministerial meeting at the
WTO a year ago and that was a very good
initiative I think I think we we didn't
know whether the US would engage and
whether that would be a meaningful
platform but but it was it turned out to
be very constructive and we have now had
four ministerial meetings and we are
trying to see can we can be together
draft new rules in the WTO rules where
we would address big issues which are
some of the root causes of the problems
of the WTO meaning rules on industrial
subsidies rules on forced technology
transfer we have also drafted a proposal
jointly that has been joined by some
other countries as well on how to
increase transparency notification
within the WTO that sounds very boring
and procedural but is actually about
making the WTO work better and gaining
trust again and that is now disgusting
in the
but within the institutions of WTO so
that is a way where where we are
engaging with the with us and they say
they think it's meaningful and we are
also now - yesterday we presenter
together with I think 11 other countries
a proposal on how to reform and
strengthen the apparatus system where
the US have been blocking the
appointment of the arbitrator or the
judges and that is also an attempt to
say that we have listened to some other
concerns that we share and here is a way
forward so now we hope that the US will
look at this will engage will sit with
us and we can go through the proposals
and hopefully we can unblock the the
situation because if we don't have an
applet body within the WTO we're in a
big very big problem so on that specific
issue I think the Americans have been
quite dismissive of the efforts so far I
mean they're on the record as saying
everything that's been proposed hasn't
gone far enough and it does sort of
strike me I'm not convinced that anyone
else can do more than they're doing but
it did somewhat strike me that this is a
technocratic fix to a political problem
that and lessened until the Americans
feel that there are rooms that they can
pursue through the dispute settlement
but you know new rooms on subsidies new
rooms on tech transfer then attempting
to reform the judicial branch itself
it's not going to be enough for them
well all this is speculation but the
appellate body absolutely I mean they
need to be strengthened and to be
reformed and and one could imagine a few
things to do yes that is technocratic
but it's it's the dispute settlement
mechanism that we have it's been very
useful for the EU but it's been
extremely useful for the u.s. as well
they are still taking cases to the WTO
so somehow they are expecting a body to
be there then that body if it's going to
serve the purposes of 164 members has to
be independent it has to have a lot of
integrity it cannot be a political body
taking orders from one one or two
capitals that is the red line for for us
and but at the same time we are also I
mean there's so many things we need to
do we are working with the u.s. to write
these new rules on subsidies on
transfer and so on and ideally I mean
they would fit together in in a
strengthened and reformed WTO in the
future but for this we need the u.s. to
engage because they've been criticizing
it okay fine
fair enough but how do you go from there
you have to come with concrete proposals
now we have come proposals now it's up
to them to respond and to see okay what
I do are these proposals fine do you
have others how do we move forward and
that's the intention with these these
proposals that many many countries and
big economies are supporting and if they
don't move forward in time and the
appellate body does in fact go into a
halt do you have a plan B can you bypass
the Americans can you use majority
voting can you set up other structures
within the WTO I mean you must be
considering all of you Dan but I don't
think it's useful to even discuss a plan
B before we've tested the plan a yet and
that's what we do now if it came to it
first in the Financial Times I would
discuss it with a few other countries
now
that's not always the case commission is
it worth doing any good just to explore
that though I mean of course I you don't
want to speak hypothetically I want you
to speak hypothetically you don't want
to be that's in the nature of our
respective professions but is there
anything that would be helpful that
would would actually bypass is anything
that bypasses the Americans in the WTO
helpful at all or will it be more
trouble than it's worth because you know
my my personal view is that you can come
up with a half-dozen technocratic fixes
but that is only likely to cause
Americans to destroy this is no station
to destroy the W I want to altogether
well we don't know that and and this
what you call technocratic proposals
which hurts me a little bit because it's
been very difficult to draft them into
it to engage it's it's a way to see do
you really want to engage do you care
about the upper body at all or do you
want to scrap the whole system and do
something else now it's time for them to
come out of the woods and and say what
would what do you want and this is our
fair and I think very ambitious attempt
yet because if you want to change with
the rules in an international body it
has to be technocratic unless you want
to transform into a very political body
and we don't want to do that and as I
said in the meantime we are working with
us and we have it goes quite well
actually to write those rules that are
the most critical there are many things
we need to do in the WTO but to try to
draft new rules on on the two issues
we've been discussing and then there's
so many other things we need to do in in
the WTO as well long term and short term
so I mean it's an attempt of course the
world the World Trade Organization
without the US would be a much poorer
organization we would need them inside
so we will do what we can to make sure
that they they they engage if they say
and they haven't said that so openly and
clearly that they don't care and they
want to withdraw from WTO okay then
we'll have to think about what to do
next but we are not there yet
hopefully we won't get there either or
dealing more generally on dealing with
us you said at the beginning we've had
to learn new
ways of doing it differently what's the
word
mercurial nature of the President and of
us pay policy are there any general
lessons at all that you have drawn that
you can draw from how to deal with this
administration I think we are trying to
find find ways and discuss with other
countries as well I mean we it is a
little bit unpredictable but we do it
the way we can we have tried to find
common ground with the Americans we
discussed this trilateral with the
Japanese which i think is working well
we had this meeting in the White House
in in July where we try to find a common
platform and working from that to see
how we can facilitate trade between us
that is the platform we have for the
moment so we need to explore that see if
if this is something where that could
lead to you know something that is
mutually beneficial because a grand
trade agreement between the EU and the
u.s. is still a very good idea but it's
not possible for the moment but there
are things we could do if there is will
on both sides that meeting the July
meeting which the e of the u.s. agreed
to negotiate first of all quite simply
were you surprised that the Americans
were so open to that offer it had been
prepared and and but he came in in a
difficult moment of course the rhetoric
was quite tough that was the same week
that President Trump had said that he
was a foe and that the European Union
was created to take advantage of the
United States so of course there the
rhetoric there what was a bit tense and
and the intention of President jung-geun
I think he succeeded beautifully and
honey really you know sort of created a
good atmosphere and he was friendly and
constructive to see if we despite these
harsh words can we you know can we come
back to the idea that Europe and the US
have so much together we have a history
we have a future can we build something
constructive of that and that that went
rather well you saw the press conference
it was all hugging and kissing
now on the the substance of that deal I
know the spin I've heard the spin the
spin is it's fine to sign a deal with
the country that doesn't adhere to the
Paris climate change agreement because
it's not a general comprehensive deal
I've also heard well we'll try and get
the coverage up to the point where it's
substantially on trade as required to
the WTO at the moment it excludes
agriculture and and cars but
realistically
doesn't it look doesn't I mean on the
optics that as soon as there was a
direct threat to the EU economy and
particularly let's be honest too German
car makers the e use principles
essentially got jumped well we're not
negotiating anything yet
what we offered and that was with the
unanimous support of member states
because of course the Commission cannot
do anything without the member states
was that we could engage in a smaller
trade agreement focused on industrial
goods we said that we we are willing to
include the whole vehicle out to outer
sector as well and that would be
beneficial for for all of us that hasn't
started yet
we haven't started any scoping we
haven't started any negotiations there
is no mandate we have offered to start
the scoping but the u.s. just asked just
a couple of weeks ago to Congress to get
the trade promotion Authority and that
is a process that is now in Congress and
during that period there is no you know
no negotiations we're not negotiating
anything yet of course I will not get
when if we do we will have to see what
would be in that negotiation it will
have to be WTO compatible as you say and
then ask the Member States for a mandate
but but we're not there yet so what we
are focusing on is the regulatory
component which is outside the trade
agreement on a voluntary basis but where
we also could get some some mutually
beneficial things here we did a few good
things in teacher we can build upon that
and it's also about you know making it a
bit easier in in some key sectors for
both of us medical devices Pharma maybe
machinery that some of the new standards
as well there are so many new
standards just waiting to be set outside
out in the world and if we can set them
together I think that could be very
beneficial we could have global you us
stand us and then the others would have
to follow so that's what we are
discussing that is not very sexy it's
not very easy to summarize in a tweet
but it's very important to facilitate
trade and it would mean a lot for our
industries on both sides okay so let me
ask you a final question which is
something politicians like doing even
less than hypotheticals which is
forecasting once the current Commission
comes to an end do you think the trade
under the next Commissioner is going to
be easier last four years how do you
think it will be different it's not
reluctance that I don't want to
speculate it's a very difficult one well
trade I think as it has become
politicized in a way that it wasn't
before and that is here to stay so I
think the next Commission would still
have to make sure that that trade is
inclusive and transparent engaging like
we do today for instance and there are
still a lot of trade agreements that
have not been done that are out there
waiting we have India for instance that
I will read read the hand leave to my
successor and with with the American
administration I think it would still be
a bit challenging and where we are in in
the sort of trade war between US and
China and it will still affect the
European Union a lot so it's probably
still going to be very difficult so I
wish my successor good luck thank you